[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Welcome to
the mid-term review of 14.13.
Tonight, as I
mentioned before, there
will be three types of
questions on the exam.
There will be
true/false/uncertain questions.
These are questions where
you're given a statement,
and you can ascertain
whether the statement is
true or false or uncertain.
True means essentially
it's strictly true
and it's always true, or false
means it's strictly false,
and there's a counterexample
that's shows you it's false.
And uncertain means like without
having further information,
you cannot actually
answer the questions.
So you cannot really make
a statement whether that
statement is true or false.
In any of the ones you
do, please always explain
your answers carefully.
So just writing true,
false, or uncertain
will almost surely
or will surely not
give you full credit.
You have to explain
your answers.
It doesn't actually matter that
much whether you get it right,
whether the statement is
true, or false, or uncertain,
as long as your answer is
actually reasonable and shows
some understanding
of the material.
So the quality of your
answer is quite important.
We also want you to
provide intuitions.
We do not want you to just write
some math and nothing else.
You can use some math
to sort of clarify
your answer or the
like, but you always
need to provide a verbal
explanation and some intuition
and some explanation of why
you think the answer might be
or the statement
might be true, false,
or [AUDIO OUT] your answer.
For multiple choice
questions, you're essentially
given different
choices, and you just
pick one answer with no
further explanation needed.
Very simple.
And then there will be sort
of pset-style questions
that sort of you're familiar
with, either from like psets
or like previous exams.
These will be quite similar
to the psets questions.
It will be sort of generally
not on the harder side,
just, you know, we only have
so much time to do this.
There will be some
algebra involved.
Again, please always explain
your answers carefully.
Now, what materials are
you responsible for?
You're responsible for the
lectures up to and including
lecture 12, which was
the lecture on March 11,
up to slide 67 of
lectures 11, or lecture--
the notes for the lecture,
the handout of the notes for
lectures 11 through 13.
You're also responsible for
recitations 1 through 5,
recitations 6, now, which the
recitation that Will gave,
which is quite similar
to this one, and 7.
These recitations
are just reviews
that might be helpful
for some of you.
But there's no new material
that we use that [INAUDIBLE]
right now.
Psets 1 to 3 are sort
of part of the deal.
And readings, starred
or non-starred readings
cited in class are only
relevant to the extent
that they appear in
lectures and/or recitation.
But to say, like if I discuss
a certain paper and the content
of that paper, the content
of the people that's
discussed in the class
is relevant to you.
However, anything
that's in the paper that
doesn't appear in the
lecture is not relevant,
as in like, we're not going
to ask you questions that
sort of ask about some
obscure details of the papers
that you never heard
about in class.
How do you get
ready for the exam?
Well, you study, study that the
lecture and presentation slides
carefully.
You should make sure you're
familiar and comfortable
with the psets and
the solutions make
you understand and are able to
solve the psets on your own.
A great resource practice is
to do those psets and exams.
Again, readings, starred and
non-starred, are not required,
but they may sort of help
you deepen your understanding
of the material, and maybe
sometimes the lecture
notes a little bit.
[AUDIO OUT] dense and don't
have that much detail.
So you can sort of like try
to consult them, and try
to understand the material
as best or better.
But we won't ask you about
the details of those readings
beyond those details of
was covered in class.
So let me now sort of review
the material overall and sort
of give you a sense of what
are the kinds of things
that we want to know.
To be clear, this
is not exhaustive
in the sense of like, there
are some other materials
in the lecture slides that
I'm not mentioning here.
What I'm trying
to do here is just
give you a sense
for a lot of what
the most important key
things that you should know.
This will cover
perhaps like 80%,
90% of the material
that's actually
potentially in the exam.
Having said that, you
know you should really
go through the entire
lecture slides,
make sure you're sort
of gathering everything
in understanding
what's going on there.
OK.
So the first thing we discuss,
these time preferences
in particular, the
exponential discounting model.
Here, you should know, what
is the exponential discounting
model?
What is delta, the time
preference parameter
that model?
What does it measure?
How can we estimate it, assuming
that an exponential discounting
model is correct?
Further, what are
the main assumptions
of exponential
discounting model,
and what evidence do we have
against those assumptions?
So lectures 3 and 4
discussed those assumptions
and the evidence against
these assumptions in detail.
And after that, we discussed
the quasi-hyperbolic discounting
model, which is a relatively
small modification
of the exponential
discounting model.
Again, you know
what is this model?
How is it different from the
exponential discounting model?
And of course, the
difference is that there's
a present bias
parameter of beta that
is added to this model, which
measures short-run discounting,
as in like, how much weight
you put on the present,
versus everything else
that's in the future.
Now, what empirical evidence
can the quasi-exponential,
quasi-hyperbolic
model explain better
than the exponential discounting
model, and why is that?
So you should be familiar
with, for example,
things like preference
reversals and then [INAUDIBLE]
commitment.
Why is that consistent with
the quasi-hyperbolic model?
And you know, why
is it not consistent
with the exponential model?
Of course, that's
what we discussed
in the previous slide, is
the somewhat the assumptions
of the exponential discount
model, where for example, one
of the key assumptions are
that there are no preference
reversals.
And we discussed that in detail.
Then, of course you need
to know in the course
of hyperbolic discounting model,
what is this sophistication?
What is naivete?
And what is partial naivete?
So what does theta measure?
What does theta hat measure?
What is full sophistication,
full naivete,
and partial naivete?
And answer questions
such as like,
does sophistication make
people always better off?
And why, or why not,
if that's the case?
Further, you should understand,
what is demand for commitment?
Who demands commitment
and who doesn't?
Or like are fully
sophisticated or fully naive
people, or partial naive
people potentially demanding
commitment?
What are the
conditions under which
somebody demands commitment?
And what kinds of people do
not, or do demand commitment?
And what kinds of people
benefit from doing so?
And in particular, can
people be worse off
from being offered
a commitment device?
And why is that, or why not?
Next, we discussed
in quite a bit
of detail empirical
applications from a range
of different settings.
This is lecture 5 and 6.
So we want you to
be familiar with
those empirical applications.
You should understand why the
quasi-hyperbolic model can
explain or cannot explain
some of the empirical evidence
better than the exponential
discounting model.
And I think you know , kind
of like why do we think
quasi-hyperbolic model is a good
fit for some of the empirical
examples that I have shown?
Then you need to be
able to solve problems.
These are similar problems to
the problems in the problem
sets that you have seen
before, problem sets
for people either like
exponential discounters,
or like for beta delta
equals, where beta equals 1,
and delta being like
either 1, or 0.95,
or close to 1, because
hyperbolic discounters,
and again, fully naive, fully
sophisticated, and partially
naive agents.
How does one solve
such problems?
Of course, we had
plenty of practice
already in the psets
in the term examples,
also it's in the finals.
So you should use
backwards or forwards
induction or iteration,
depending on the kinks.
I sort of discuss this in
slide 62 of lectures 3 and 4,
and slide 37 of
lectures 5 and 6.
There's also a recitation
that covers that in detail.
So you should have plenty
of practice of doing so.
Now, let me now give
you some examples
of what are some examples
true/false/uncertain questions,
and how should you answer them?
So let me sort of just read
the statements for you,
and you can think about
this for a second.
And then we're going
to give you the answer.
So consider individuals with
beta delta preferences--
this is quasi-hyperbolic
discounters--
who only differ by
their present bias--
had like beta equals
between 0 and 1.
And suppose there's a commitment
savings device available.
Their willingness to pay
for this commitment device
strictly decreases in beta.
Now, is that a true
or false statement?
The answer is this
statement is false.
Now, why is that?
Well, there's, again, like
if you just click false,
that's not going to
give you full credit,
even if, in fact, the
statement is false.
What you need to do is you
need to sort of provide
some further explanation.
Ideally, you'll provide us
like a somewhat detailed
explanation, so that
you know if it's false,
if you provide several
examples, that's should better
amount than just one.
In this case, why is it false?
Well, A, individuals
might be naive, right?
So in particular, if
people are fully naive,
they will not be
willing to pay anything
for commitment devices.
So regardless to the
beta, willingness to pay
will always be 0.
So it would surely
not decrease in beta.
Second, the commitment
device may just not
be effective at all.
If the commitment
device is useless,
it doesn't matter what beta is,
nobody will demand commitment
anyway.
And finally, even if
individuals-- this
is a little bit more
trickier explanation,
and I wouldn't
necessarily expect
you to know that
answer-- but even
if individuals are
fully sophisticated
and devices effective, the
commitment device is effective,
willingness to pay, it may not
be strictly decreasing in beta.
And here's sort of an example.
Well, if beta equals
0 or beta equals 1,
then individuals would
be willing to pay 0
for the commitment
device, right?
Because if beta equals 0, they
don't care about the future.
If beta equals 1,
they just don't
need any commitment devices.
But in between, the
willingness to pay
might be positive for
betas between 0 and 1.
That essentially means
that willingness to pay
would be an inverse U in beta.
Again, that's a bit
of a tricky answer.
Like the third bullet point,
we wouldn't necessarily
expect you to know that answer.
But you should be able to say or
to answer reason one, or reason
two in this specific case.
Second example statement--
fully sophisticated
individuals can experience
large welfare losses
from their present bias.
The answer is this is true.
Why is that?
I'll let you think
about this for a second.
Well, the answer
is that awareness
of present bias, that
is, like sophistication,
does not remove present bias.
Even if people
are sophisticated,
the present bias is still there.
There might be some
commitment devices,
some ways in which people are
able to overcome the losses
associated with present bias.
But in the absence of
commitment devices,
people may still make
suboptimal decisions.
And some of these
decisions might, in fact,
induce large welfare needs.
We discussed some
examples in class,
sort of numerical
examples, where
you could see that sophisticated
people might actually
be worse off than naive
people, and could in fact
suffer quite a bit from or
similar to the large welfare
losses.
With the present
bias, all of this
is evaluated by the
long-run [INAUDIBLE] ideas
of like if somebody makes
choices for the future where
the beta is not
relevant, compared
to that kind of
welfare criterion,
people might be a lot worse
off due to their present bias.
OK, here's example number three.
Present bias individuals
always have positive demand
for commitment devices.
Again, the statement is false.
Why is that?
And we kind of
discussed this already
in the previous questions.
Now, let me be very explicit.
There's sort of
three conditions that
must be met for positive
demand for commitment.
I discussed this in class.
We know that person
must be present biased,
or have some form of some
self-control problems.
Individuals must--
the person must
be aware of the present bias,
so they can't be fully naive.
They could be partially naive,
but it can't be fully naive.
And the individual must
perceive the commitment device
as effective in helping overcome
the self-control problem.
That's to say, if somebody is
offered a commitment device,
and that commitment
device is useless,
well, there's not going to
be any demand for commitment,
particularly if the person
perceives that the commitment
device is useless.
Notice that that
person might actually
perceive the commitment
device to be effective,
while in reality, it's not.
So they might have some
positive demand for commitment,
even if the commitment
device is in reality useless,
because their beliefs are
wrong, because of essentially
some form of partial naivete.
But it cannot be that the person
perceives the commitment device
as not effective, because
then the person would just not
demand it in the first place.
Now, that makes now
the statement false.
When only the first condition
of the three is met,
as in like the person's
only present-biased,
then we cannot be sure that
there will be positive demand
for commitment.
And so the statement,
as had been said,
is false, because we said
sort of like always have
positive demand for commitment.
If it were without
the always, then
you could also answer uncertain,
because then you would say,
well, it depends
on their naivete,
or on the sophistication, or
it depends on how effective
the commitment device is.
But the way the statement is
written, it says like, always.
And so now, you
can easily come up
with some counterexamples that
show that the statement in fact
is false.
The second topic
that we discussed
after time preferences
was risk preferences,
in particular expected utility.
So here, you know,
you need to have
a clear understanding of what
is the expected utility model?
What is risk aversion?
Why are people risk averse?
How is risk aversion
specifically modeled
in the expected utility model?
What is the expected
monetary value?
And also things like
what is concavity?
What does concavity
have to do-- what
is the expected utility versus
the expected monetary value?
And what does the concavity
imply for risk aversion
in the expected utility model?
Then next, how can we
measure risk aversion
within the expected
utility model?
In particular, we
discussed three types
of ways of measuring
risk aversion.
We discuss certainty
equivalents.
We discussed choices
from gambles.
We also discussed
insurance choices.
This is the Sydnor paper.
And then, we discussed what is
problematic about the estimates
of risk aversion in the
expected utility model.
In particular, we
discussed evidence
that found that there tends to
be substantial small-scale risk
aversion, so when you
give people small gambles,
they tend to be
quite risk averse
or they tend to have a
very quite high gamma.
But we know also from large
scale choices that the risk
aversion cannot be actually
that high when people make these
choices.
People leave the house
every day and engage
in quite a few risks.
In the long run, they
hold stocks and so on.
This must mean
that their long run
using sort of long-run choices,
that implies essentially
a relatively low gamma.
But since the expected utility
model only has like one
parameter, it cannot explain
both of those features and sort
of ignores this trouble.
So essentially, if you try
to match a small-scale risk
aversion, then you need to have
a very large gamma, high gamma.
If you try to match
large-scale risk aversion,
you need to have a low gamma.
And that sort of brings
trouble, because you can't just
explain both of those things.
And sort of Matthew
Rabin in Rabin & Thaler,
as well as recitation 4 discuss
this conundrum and this issue
and in quite a bit of detail.
Next, we discussed Kahneman and
Tversky's 1979 prospect theory.
This is a seminal paper.
And if you'd remember just a
few papers from this class,
this is one of the papers that
you should really know about.
So what evidence in
Kahneman and Tversky
is inconsistent with
expected utility?
Well, in particular, sort
of several things in there,
but you discuss mostly
one feature, which
is risk aversion
in the gain domain,
and risk lovingness
in the loss domain.
And so, now, what are
the most important points
from Kahneman and
Tversky's prospect theory--
this is sort of the
proposed alternative
to expected utilities.
This is on slide 3
of 51 of lecture 9,
where there's sort of three
futures discussed there.
One is like changes rather
than levels are the arguments
of the utility function.
Then there's loss aversion.
So there's a kink of the utility
function around the reference
point.
And there's diminishing
sensitivity,
meaning the utility function
is concave in the gain domain
or [INAUDIBLE] above the
reference point and is convex.
And the last domain would be
below the reference point.
OK, so now, what does sort
of this proposed alternative
utility or value
function look like?
How does it incorporate
the three features again?
We sort of discussed this
and this utility function
in lecture 9 that talks
about this in detail.
Or the lecture talks about this
utility function in detail.
One key question here, that
is, how is the reference point
determined?
What are some candidate
reference points?
So one candidate would
be the status quo.
Another reference point
candidate would be expectation.
But there could be
also other things,
such as goal and aspirations.
Recitation 5 discuss
this a little bit,
not in too much detail.
Then, we discussed empirical
evidence, in particular,
what empirical evidence of
loss aversion do we have?
We talked about
small-scale gambles.
We talked about the endowment
effect, in particular.
And then we discussed some
applications in lecture 9.
So what are these applications?
We discuss labor supply,
the housing market, stocks,
marathon running, and golf.
So you should be familiar with
these empirical applications
from lecture 9.
You should in
particular understand
why reference-dependent
preferences can explain
some of the empirical
evidence that
is showed better than the
expected utility models.
You should understand,
is some of the evidence
that we see consistent with
the expected utility model?
And if not, why not?
And why is the
reference-dependent model--
in particular, which feature of
the reference-dependent model
can explain the loss.
What are the features again?
Changes rather than levels--
some reference point,
reference-dependence, the loss
aversion and
diminished sensitivity,
so which feature is
actually important?
Explaining things, we focused
mostly on loss aversion.
What is not relevant is the
deal or no deal evidence
and the paper by Pierce et al.
There's a couple of slides
at the end of lecture 9
that I didn't really cover
or didn't cover at all.
So we're not going to ask
any questions about that.
So now, how do
you solve problems
with reference-dependent
preferences?
You can see problem set
3, question number 1
had some questions about this.
And again, there's additional
psets and exam questions
that you could practice with.
So there are quite a few of
those kinds of questions.
Now, here is sort of some
example of a multiple choice
question, which is--
so Maddie wrote this question,
so Maddie, in fact, appears.
And the question is,
Maddie is writing
a problem set for 14.13.
She gets utility u of q from the
number of questions she writes.
She has reference-dependent
preferences
around the goal of writing
10 questions, with 10
as her reference points.
If you normalize the utility
of 10 questions to 0,
which of the following would be
consistent with loss aversion?
I'll let you have
a look at this.
So there's option A, u of
of 8 equals minus 2, u of 12
equals 1.
And number B, option B yields
8 equals minus 2, u of 12
equals 2.
And then C is, option C is u of
8 equals minus 1, and u of 12
equals 2.
So which of those answers is
consistent with loss aversion?
The answer is option
A. Now, why is that?
Well, loss aversion sort of
implies that losses hurt more
than gains help.
So with preferences
as in A, Maddie
would have the utility
cost of 2 from falling
short of her goal
of two questions,
but only a gain of 1 util
from exceeding her goal by two
questions, right?
So the goal of, the
game of exceeding,
of being by two questions above,
so being two questions above
gives her some gain of 1 util.
But the utility costs of
falling short with two
is twice as large,
which just tends
to be kind of like
the evidence that you
would see in loss aversion.
And the other two examples
don't have that feature.
So really only answer
number A is correct.
Second question.
Maddie is walking home and
passes a bakery unexpectedly.
She decides to buy a pastry.
For example, she
looks at the pastry,
and it looks really nice.
Prior to purchasing the
pastry, her maximum willingness
to pay for the pastry was P0.
Then she runs into Alan-- this
is our previous, excellent TA--
who asks to buy the
pastry from her.
She offers him the lowest price
she is willing to accept, P1.
Which of the following
comparisons between P0 and P1
is consistent with
an endowment effect,
P0 larger than P1, P0 equals
P1, or P0 smaller than P1?
The answer is answer
number C. Why is that?
Well, the endowment effect
says that people are--
when their willingness to
pay, that is in this case P0,
is smaller than their
willingness to accept,
when they accept.
That is to say, being endowed
with an item in this case,
like a pastry, increases
one's willingness to pay.
That is to say, if somebody
asks you to sell something
that you own, you
ask for more money
than you're willing to
pay in the first place
when you don't own the item.
And so the endowment effect
will then predict that,
or the endowment effect
entails that now P1 is larger
than P0, which is answer
number C. So Maddie values
the pastry more after
she has bought it,
compared to like
prior to buying it.
The third broad set of
preferences to be discussed
were social preferences.
We didn't quite
finish with this,
so we're not going to cover
everything, in particular,
not lecture 13.
And the estimation part
of social preferences,
which will apart from choices,
which will be at pset 4.
You should understand what
social preferences are.
You should also
understand how can you
measure social preferences?
In lab games, we
discussed at length
the dictator game, the ultimatum
game, and the trust game.
You should also be broadly
familiar, not in detail,
but broadly familiar
of what evidence
do we typically find in
dictator and ultimatum games?
For instance, in
dictator games, people
tend to give something like
20% to 30% of their share.
People tend to be quite
nice in those games.
Now, then we discussed then
like given that evidence,
so given that people look quite
nice in these types of games,
there's also some other
evidence people give
to charity or things like that.
Do we think that is
evidence of people
being generally nice to others
because of poor altruism?
Or if not, why not?
We discussed sort of three
sets of evidence in particular.
We discussed the costly exit or
exit options in dictator games.
So people essentially won't
be able to leave the dictator.
They rather sort
of leave and give,
and sort of keep the money.
Or they're willing to pay
some small amount of money
to leave the
dictator game and not
having to face
some other person,
but it then feel compelled
to give to others.
There was the option of
hiding behind the computer.
If a computer gives
you the option
to hide behind the computer
to be mean to others,
you might take advantage of
that and actually be meaner
than you would be otherwise.
So altruism, or people's giving
tends to go down quite a bit
when they're able to
hide behind the computer.
So both of those types
of pieces of evidence
are evidence of social image
being important in giving.
People care a lot about
what others think,
in particular what
others think about them,
and they don't want
to upset others.
And so if they're able to
avoid those kind of situations,
they might be able to--
they might want to do that,
which would suggest that it's
not really that they want
others to do well in the sense
that they really want others
to have money or more money
than before, but rather it's
because of social pressure
or social image concerns,
people might give
in dictator or ultimatum games.
Moreover, there's some
evidence of self-image
about people caring about what
they think about themselves.
They want to think of themselves
as being a good person.
And so the evidence of
the moral wiggle room
seems to suggest that these
concerns are quite important.
In particular, people are
engaging in some behavior
where they delude themselves
that they are in fact nice,
when in reality, they're not.
So that's discussed in
detail in the lecture.
Again, we will not
ask, and so you
should be familiar with
this type of evidence.
And you should be familiar
why that sort of tells us
that people are perhaps not as
nice as you might have thought.
They are just coming from like
dictator or ultimatum games,
or from like donations.
We will not ask you
about models that
estimate social preferences.
That will be in problem set
4, so don't worry about that.
Sort of the stuff on [INAUDIBLE]
and Rabin that's there,
we will not ask you about that.
OK, so then here's
another example
of a true/false/uncertain
question.
Statement, if a person
gives 0 in a dictator game,
this is evidence that
this person is selfish.
Now, the answer is false.
I think if you
answer it uncertain,
that would also be fine.
Why is that?
Well, the person might
give 0 to the other person
in the dictator game and then
donate the money to someone
in greater need, right?
And then that person is
in fact really quite nice.
Second, the person
might be very poor
relative to the other
person in the game.
So her marginal utility
is just very high.
So now, even if you
have like equal weights
to your own utility and
the other person's utility,
since the marginal utility of
giving $10 to yourself compared
to the other person is way
higher than the other person's
marginal utility, you would just
give everything to yourself.
And that doesn't mean you
don't care about others.
It just means
like, in fact, even
if you were sort of
like a social climber,
you would give it
to that person,
because that person
was like a huge meany,
or the rich person just might
not really need that money.
Looking at this more
closely, actually, I
think uncertain would be a
better answer here, and not
false.
I just wrote this
question fairly quickly.
So if the question says--
if the question
instead were to say,
this is conclusive evidence
that this person is selfish,
then it would be false.
Or this would be,
this is clearly
evidence where
this person must be
selfish, that would be false.
The way it's written right now,
it's rather sort of uncertain,
because we just
don't quite know.
It could be that the
person is really selfish.
Or it could be that the person--
it could be this evidence
that the person is selfish.
But it could be the other two
reasons that I just mentioned.
OK, so now, finally, I'm going
to give you a long question,
or an example of
a long question.
And this is the question
of laptop policies.
We talked about a little
bit earlier in class,
in fact in the first lecture.
And we had the first
problem set about this.
And this is sort of like
an algebraic version
of that kind of question.
So assume the 14.13
students are present
biased with beta small
than 1 and delta equals 0.
All students have
the same beta smaller
than 1 and delta equals 0.
But they differ in
the value they derive
from using laptops in class.
L is constant for each
student from class to class,
but uniformly distributed
across students on the interval
between 0 and 1.
So some people have
like a huge value
of using the laptop in class.
And others do not.
Each lecture generates
no immediate utility.
So it's neither fun nor
like annoying or the like.
But it does give a benefit,
a future benefit of V.
So like you might
learn something,
or there's some things that
might be valuable to you
in the future.
Using a laptop reduces
the long-run benefit by D.
This might be like
distractions, in particular.
So you might be
distracted during class
when you use a laptop.
So the future benefits
are diminished by that.
Maybe he had said something
really insightful,
you didn't pay attention,
and so now, the benefits
is B minus D if
you use a laptop.
Both B and D are the
same for all students.
So there's no variation
across students there.
The only variation's coming
from some students who really,
really like using laptops
for various reasons, perhaps
because they like to
surf the internet.
Perhaps they're really
in need of using laptops
because that allows them
to take proper notes.
So in summary, a student
uses a laptop in class--
sorry, a student that
uses the laptop in class
gets immediate utility L and
future, undiscounted utility
of B minus D. And a student
who does not use a laptop
gets immediate utility of 0 and
future discounted utility of V.
So and now the social
planner is not present biased
and seeks to maximize the
utility of 14.13 students
from his perspective, OK?
First question.
Show that students are just
indifferent between using
and not using a laptop
in the current class
if L equals beat
times D. Explain
why students with
lower values of L--
so that's like L being
lower than beta D--
don't use laptops in
class, but students
with higher values of L--
so L exceeds beta D--
do use laptops in class.
OK, so now what
we're going to do
is we're going to write down the
utilities from the two choices.
That's essentially already
given in the explanation,
except for that we need to be
careful of where the beta comes
in, right?
So if students use
a laptop in class,
they get the immediate benefit
of L. And then in the future,
they get what's discounted by
beta, which is beta times B
minus D, right, because
both B and D are very far
in the future.
These are the benefits, or the
diminished benefits, B minus D,
that they get in the future.
L is in the present, so
there's no beta here.
Instead, if someone uses no
laptop, the students get 0.
So there's no laptop
benefits in the present.
And the benefits in
the future, the value
of the lecture the
future is undiminished,
which means essentially,
it's just V.
So the person just gets
0 plus beta times V.
Now, students who are
indifferent, by definition,
have the same utility of using
laptops and using no laptop.
So we can essentially just
equate those two things.
Notice that like the beta
times B is always there.
So it sort of
essentially just cancels.
And then what we get is the
person that's indifferent,
for that person, L
equals beta times D.
Now, students that
choose not to use laptops
will have low valuations
L of using laptops,
while students that
choose to use the laptops
have high L, right?
If L is very large, then
it exceeds beta times D.
If L is very small,
then L does not exceed,
is smaller than beta times D.
So given the
indifference condition,
we have essentially, as I just
said, students that do not
use the laptop, L is smaller
than beta times D. And students
that use the laptop, for them,
L is larger than beta times D.
OK.
OK, now question number two.
Now consider the policy that
allows students to use laptops
only if they sign up in advance
to sit in a laptop section.
This is a little bit different
than we had in class,
but it's a version, or
something that I also
considered, in fact, in
previous years that that
was what was used.
Now, the question here is, why
is L larger or equal than D,
not L is larger
equal than beta D,
the threshold for opting
in to the laptop section?
OK?
So now this is a
choice for people
to choose not for
the present, when
they come to class, whether they
want to use a laptop right now.
But instead, they
sign up in advance
to sit in a laptop section
for the rest of the semester.
So essentially, people
are in the present,
and they choose for the future
whether they can use laptops
in class.
Now, the utility
is now different.
And the key difference is that
the laptop benefits are now
in the future, right?
So the utility of using a laptop
now again is 0 in the present.
And this is-- again,
we make choices
in the present for the future.
There's going to be no
utility in the present.
There's no lecture right now,
no laptop benefits and the like.
And in the future, everything
is discounted by beta now,
because the person is
present biased potentially.
So it's beta times
L plus B minus D.
The utility of not using
a laptop is just 0 again.
Like in the present,
nothing happens.
And then in the future,
the benefits, as before,
are beta times D. So the
only thing that you prepare
is choice, or these two
options, the previous version,
is the L now is
discounted by beta.
But before, it was not.
Let me just go back here.
So here, you see the
L was like sort of--
here, you see the L
not discounted by beta.
This is when people make
choices for the present.
Instead, here now, the
L is discounted by beta,
because that choice is--
the laptop benefits
are in the future.
Now, we can do the
same thing as before.
Threshold for opting
in is defined as like--
or you can say that's
essentially the indifference
conditions.
You can just equalize the two,
the utility of using the laptop
or not using the laptop.
And what you now get is that if
L is larger than D, or larger
equals than D, then the
person uses the laptop.
And otherwise, they do not.
Now, why does the threshold
now change from beta D to--
sorry, from beta times D to D?
Well, because when laptop use
can only happen in the future,
all benefits and costs are
discounted at the same rate,
and that that rate is beta.
OK, question number three.
Assume there's no
laptop policy at all.
Show that if beta times
D is smaller than L
and smaller than D,
the student engages
in preference reversals.
She prefers not to use the
laptop in future classes
but changes her mind while
she's actually sitting
in those future classes.
That's sort of essentially
the typical behavior
of present bias.
People that, when
they're present biased,
for at least some parameter
of constellations,
people engage in present bias.
So let's do the math and
see what comes out here.
So when thinking about
the future laptop use,
this student's problem is
identical to the problem
in part B, sorry, in part 2.
Why is that?
Well, because she
discounts time,
both one and two periods
in advance, by beta.
Essentially, everything
is in the future,
so you just discount
everything by beta.
That's exactly kind of the
choice that we just had.
So when thinking
about future class,
where thinking about opting
in into a laptop section,
the person makes a
choice for the future.
So here, when she thinks about
any future choices, what really
matters is essentially the value
of the laptop is in the future,
I mean back in like part
2 that we just solved.
Now, we know from part 2 that
if L equals smaller than D,
then she would like to
not use the laptop, right?
So we just solve for
that in part number 2.
But from part number 1, we
know that if beta D is smaller
than L, she will end up using
the laptop when she's actually
sitting in the future class.
That is to say, if she has
a choice in any given class
and shows up in class,
she will say, oh,
like using the laptop
would be great.
The same would be true
of phones, by the way.
And when she has a choice
in any given class that
happens right now, if beta
D equals smaller than L,
she will end up using
the laptop in class.
So that implies essentially
like a preference reversal using
these parameter assumptions.
She prefers not to use the
laptop in future classes
but switches her mind or changes
her mind when she's actually
sitting in those future classes.
OK, question number 4.
Explain why the fraction 1
minus beta D of the class
uses a laptop in part 1, but
fraction 1 minus D of the class
uses the laptop in part 2.
Why does a smaller
share of the class
use their laptop in part 2?
All right, so now we're
just essentially comparing
part 1 and part 2.
And I'm going to look at
what fraction of people
are actually using the laptop.
So we can sort of
do the math version
and think about why
that answer makes sense.
So in part 1, a
student uses the laptop
if L is larger than beta
times D. If F is CDF of L--
and then started
as a puritan thing,
but to define F as the
CDF of L. And then given
the uniform distribution,
the probability
of L being larger than beta
D is 1 minus the CDF 1 minus
F of beta delta, which
is in this uniform.
It's just 1 minus beta D.
Now, likewise, in part 2,
a student uses a laptop
if L is larger than the D. So
we have the probability of L
being larger than D
is 1 minus the CDF
or the F of D,
which is 1 minus D.
So a smaller share uses
the laptop in part 2,
because the benefit
of using a laptop
is delayed and hence
discounted by beta.
So why is that?
Well, essentially, think
about it like this.
If somebody has
beta equals 1, which
is kind of equivalent
to like part 2, where
people made choices for the
future, if you use a laptop--
so a share of people will
like the laptop, because--
or like to use the laptop when
making choices for the future,
not because of self-control
problems or the like,
but just because they find lots
of really helpful in taking
notes.
Now, if then a person, in
addition, is present biased
and makes a choice
for the present,
that enhances the
short-run benefits,
because now the L is not
discounted by beta anymore.
And now, it's essentially,
it's given sort of the benefit.
It's in the present,
and everything else beta
is in the future.
And so that means essentially
that when making choices
for the present, the
present benefits, the L,
gets more weight relative
to everything else, which
is against the weight
of beta less than 1.
So now, if you are already, when
making choices for the future,
chose the laptop
anyway, that implies
that you also choose the
laptop for the present.
Essentially, anybody who chooses
the laptop for the future
would also choose the
laptop for the present.
And now, there are some
people essentially don't
have like huge variations.
They might not choose the
laptop for the future,
but they might choose
it, they will choose it
for the present because
of their present bias.
And therefore, then
the fraction of people
who choose for the
present will be
larger than the
fraction of people
who choose for the
future, which we just
showed using some algebra.
OK, then finally, why
would the social planner
prefer the opt-in policy to
both the the policy of allowing
students to choose whether
to use their laptops
and to banning
laptops altogether?
So let's think about through
this, the opt-in policy,
what does that really entail?
Well, the opt-in
policy, as we said,
is the planner is
not present biased.
So the planner would
only want students
with L being larger
than D to use laptops.
And so the opt-in policy,
as we just showed above,
achieves this.
So that's great.
I know like a free
choice policy instead,
students with beta times D is
smaller than L, smaller than D,
will suboptimally
use their laptops,
and the social planner
does not like this.
On the other hand,
banning laptops altogether
is suboptimal because
welfare is gained
by allowing the students with
the highest valuations, with L
equals--
sorry, L larger than D
to use laptops, right?
So banning laptops is not great
because essentially, there's
some people who
really would love
to use their laptops
regardless of present bias.
And not allowing
that is not great.
Free choice is not great,
because essentially,
once you let people
choose any given day,
temptation will sort of
kick in, and some people
will suboptimally
use their laptops
and just surf the internet
all day, or all class,
and not learn very much.
And instead, the policy where
people opt in for the future
essentially achieves
the objective
of the social planner, who
wants only students with L
larger than D to
use their laptops.
And the social planner will
be happy, and therefore
prefer that policy
over both free choice
and over banning laptops.
So that's the end.
That's all I have to say about
getting ready for the exam.
And I think you should
prepare well and try
to look at the materials.
Please ask any questions in
case things aren't clear.
Again, I have office
hours on Friday, April 3
at 4:30 to 6:00.
I emailed you about that.
[INAUDIBLE] also has office
hours from 1:30 to 3:30.
Again, that's in my email.
If you have questions,
please let us
know in particular on Piazza
or during office hours.
But in any case, please do not
worry too much about the exam.
Try your best, and
you will do great.
But you know, even if you
don't do great, you'll be fine.
You will pass this class as
long as you take the exam
and write something that
is remotely reasonable.
Thank you so much.
And I look forward to
seeing you in class soon.